to help freshmen and sophomores in
selecting their courses candid reviews
of courses and instructors compiled by
juniors and seniors
so this already feels very strange
they're giving us a subject which is
candid reviews of courses and
instructors compiled by juniors and
seniors so what they've underlined here
which we're going to think about if
there's a better way of phrasing it that
already feels like the subject of our
sentence and
because they're saying to help freshmen
and sophomores in selecting their
courses since you're giving us this
prepositional phrase it's implying that
they that the the candid reviews of
courses and instructors compiled by
junior's leaders did something
to help freshmen and sophomores in
selecting their courses but they're not
telling us what the candid reviews
they're not telling us what the stuff in
orange right over here what did they do
another way to think about it they gave
us the subject that's why over here in
orange canada reviews of courses and
instructors compiled by juniors and
seniors but they're not telling us what
they did to help freshmen and sophomores
in selecting their courses we don't know
what the what the action here is of the
sentence we don't know what the
predicate of the sentence actually is
so i don't like the
it as it is it's not really making any
sense so we can rule out the first
choice which is always the sentence as
is now let's look at let's look at the
other choices
candid reviews of courses and
instructors being compiled by juniors
and seniors so once again that just
keeps this as just a whole subject right
over here it still doesn't tell us what
this thing
did to help freshmen and sophomores in
selecting their courses there's no
predicate so i'll rule that out
and to compile candid reviews of courses
and instructors by juniors and seniors
so this one really sounds disjoint to
help freshmen sophomores in selecting
their courses
and
to compile candidate reviews of courses
and instructors by juniors and seniors
so it's really kind of it's kind of this
compound prepositional phrase and
they're really not even giving us a
subject or a predicate right over here
who's doing what
to
do this and to do this so this one is
also i would say fairly bizarre
juniors and seniors have compiled candid
reviews of course as instructors
so i like this one because this is
actually a complete sentence this is
actually a complete sentence even if you
did not have the prepositional phrase in
the beginning what's your subject here
well your subject is juniors and seniors
what did they do
well they have compiled candidate
reviews of courses and instructors so
this by itself is a complete sentence
and we could throw this prepositional
phrase on the front to say well
why did they do this to help freshmen
and sophomores in selecting their
courses so we get to help freshmen and
sophomores in selecting their courses
juniors and seniors that's the subject
have compiled candid reviews of courses
and instructors that one feels very good
let's just look at this last one
with the juniors and seniors compiling
candid reviews of courses and
instructors so once again it's just
another phrase not really giving us once
again a kind of a complete
expression here they're not giving us a
complete subject with a with an action
so i would rule this one out as well